thank you Peter for the introduction I'm
grateful to be here it's not snowing
that's a big plus for us northeasterners
I'd like to talk to you today about
something that truth be told I don't
know very much about I know this may
seem a little odd having a speaker who
doesn't know what he's talking about to
make matters worse my ignorance is not
for a lack of trying
what I'm going to talk about the brain
is something that I've studied for all
of my adult life and given my age that's
the vast majority of my life and in fact
I study it because it's so difficult to
understand and I am NOT going to provide
you with a deep insight today but at
least perhaps give you a sense of why a
deep insight is so hard to get and I'd
like to start actually by showing you
some data that came from YouTube great
place to find things let's show you
three short movies that highlight the
issue that has devilled me since I was a
graduate student and it's basically the
fact that brains become ingrained to do
things quite well but there's a certain
amount of solidness or calcification or
lack of changeability once these things
are set in become ingrained and I want
to give you a sense of this rather than
talking about this I'll just show you
these three YouTube videos the first
ones about motor systems about how we
learn to do particular things the second
one is a classic sensory system one and
the third is a little odd one about how
you can't really trust one sense like
you're hearing if another sense like
your sight is
telling you something that's at odds
with it so let's start with the first
video hey it's me Destin welcome back to
smarter every day
you've heard people say it's just like
riding a bike meaning it's really easy
and you can't forget how to do it right
but I did something I did something that
damaged my mind it happened on the
streets of Amsterdam and and I got
really scared honestly I I can't ride a
bike
like you can anymore before I show you
the video what happened I need to tell
you the back story
like many six-year-olds with a MacGyver
mullet I learned how to ride a bike when
I was really young I had learned a life
skill and I was really proud of it
everything changed though when my friend
Barney called me 25 years later where I
worked the welders are geniuses and they
like to play jokes on the engineers he
had a challenge for me he had built a
special bicycle and he wanted me to try
to ride it he had only changed one thing
when he turned the handle bar to the
left the wheel goes to the right when
you turn it to the right the wheel goes
to the left I thought this would be easy
so I hopped on the bike ready to
demonstrate how quickly I could conquer
this and here he is ladies and gentlemen
mr. Destin Sandlin first attempt riding
the bicycle
yeah yeah I couldn't do it you can see
that I'm laughing but I'm actually
really frustrated in this moment I had a
really deep revelation my thinking was
in a rut
this bike revealed a very deep truth to
me I had the knowledge of how to operate
the bike but I did not have the
understanding therefore knowledge is not
understanding look I know what you're
probably thinking
Destin's probably just an uncoordinated
engineer and can't do it but that's not
the case at all the algorithm is
associated with riding a bike in your
brain
it's just that complicated think about
it downwards force on the pedals leaning
your whole body pulling and pushing the
handlebars gyroscopic precession in the
wheels every single force is part of
this algorithm and if you change any one
part it affects the entire control
system I do not make definitive
statements that often but I'm telling
you right now you cannot ride this
bicycle you might think you can but you
can't I know this because I'm often
asked to speak at universities and
conferences and I take the bike with me
it's always the same people think
they're gonna try some trick or they
were just gonna power through it it
doesn't work your brain cannot handle
this for instance this guy I offered him
$200 just to ride this bike
ten feet across the stage everybody
thought he could do this
all right so whenever you're ready no no
you have to keep your feet
[Music]
like just our own beliefs
keep your feet on the pedal
once you have a rigid way of thinking in
your head sometimes you cannot change
that even if you want to so here's what
I did it was a personal challenge I
stayed out here in this driveway and I
practiced about five minutes every day
my neighbors made fun of me I had mini
wrecks but after eight months this
happened one day I couldn't ride the
bike and the next day I could it was
like I could feel some kind of pathway
in my brain that was now unlocked it was
really weird though it's like there's
this trail in my brain but if I wasn't
paying close enough attention to it my
brain would easily lose that neural path
and jump back onto the old road it was
more familiar with any small
distractions at all like a cell phone
ringing in my pocket would instantly
throw my brain back to the old control
algorithm and I would wreck but at least
I could ride it my son is the closest
person to me genetically and he's been
riding a normal bike for three years
that's over half his life I wanted to
know how long it would take him to learn
how to ride a backwards bike so I told
him if he learned how to ride a
backwards bike he could go with me to
Australia and meet a real astronaut are
you gonna give up go ahead
this is how it starts look at this this
is such a big deal
get up you got it did you see his brain
get it so he in how many weeks we've
been doing this two weeks in two weeks
he did something that took me eight
months to do which demonstrates that a
child has more neural plasticity am I
even saying that right than an adult
it's clear from this experiment that
children have a much more plastic brain
than adults that's why the best time to
learn a language is when you're a young
child all right
today's bike log I can ride smooth I can
ride fast I'm thinking the experiment is
over okay now I'm in Amsterdam a city
that has more bicycles than people the
question is can I ride a normal bike now
I mean I have spent all this time on
learning how to ride a bike if I go back
and try to ride a normal one will my
brain mess up so I've tweeted a smarter
every day Meetup if you will and I'm
gonna see if somebody brings a bicycle
and I'm gonna try to ride a normal bike
this was one of the most frustrating
moments of my life I had written a
normal bike since I was six but in this
moment I couldn't do it anymore I had
set out to prove that I could free my
brain from a cognitive bias but at this
point I'm pretty sure that all I proved
is that I can only read Eze ignite that
bias so what you're not seeing is just a
group of people here looking at me
looking at the strange American that
can't ride a bike because they think I'm
dumb but I'm actually two levels deep
into this because I've learned and
unlearned all right after 20 minutes of
making a fool out of myself suddenly my
brain clipped back into the old
algorithm I can't explain it but it
happened in a very specific moment
got it
my back oh wait I got it I got it okay
there it is okay
I tried to explain this to the people
around me and they just didn't get it
they thought I was faking the previous
20 minutes and I couldn't get anybody to
believe I felt like the only person on
the planet who had ever unlearned how to
ride a bike and I couldn't articulate it
to anyone because everybody just knew
that you can't forget how to ride a bike
so I learn three things from this
experiment I learned that welders are
often smarter than engineers I learned
that knowledge does not equal
understanding and I learned that truth
is truth no matter what I think about it
so be very careful how you interpret
things because you're looking at the
world with a bias whether you think you
are or not I'm Destin you're getting
smarter every day of Charlie Chaplin but
wait as it comes around you'll see will
you that it's hollow the back of it
coming around now is actually a hollow
mask appears to rotate in the opposite
direction and amazing that a nose sticks
out although it's actually sticking in
coming around now is the normal correct
as it were faith and weight again as it
comes around and you'll see this
extraordinary thing like Jekyll and Hyde
both the noses stick out because it's so
unlikely that the nose sticks in that a
face is hollow so you see it was convex
although it's in fact concave as now and
then it'll become the normal face again
yeah and notice of features appear in
the hollow inside it will look convex as
though it's a normal face almost there
it isn't as soon as the features appear
there your brain refuses to see it is
hollow simply because it is so unlikely
and this demonstrates the immense power
of top-down knowledge which could
actually counter signals brought them up
from the senses and force an
extraordinary illusion in which the
sensory information of the present is
canceled by immense knowledge derived
from the past because you've seen so
many faces Oh was their noses sticking
out so it's just impossible to see that
as correctly all right okay so we have
one more and this one it's called the
McGurk effect it's a very famous
psychological phenomenon you're going to
hear a person say what a sheep says baa
sheep say lambs and father
that's all that's that's all that's
gonna be said is baa but I think you
will find it very hard to hear it as baa
when you watch this and at any time you
think that it's another sound just close
your eyes and you'll hear it's just ba
and there is what the final part of it
is the same person is there are three
pictures of him and depending on which
one you look at it'll sound different
weird so you can't even trust your ears
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
so all of these things talk to a kind of
ingrained miss that somehow despite your
rational brain you cannot overcome these
illusions or these ways of doing things
whether it's motor or sensory it's the
same and this implies that once you get
a learned Association perhaps between
the shape of the lips and tongue and a
sound
it's just hardwired hardwired we talked
about this I'm sure you've heard this
term maybe we're hardwired maybe like a
radio is soldered and hardwired I want
to go back to why neurobiologists think
that this word hardwired is not actually
a bad word to think about this because
the brain actually is made up of wires
and this was the great discovery of the
father maybe we could say the mother of
neurobiology but it was a man so she
could say if the father of neurobiology
rimoni kaha Santiago Ramon iike Hall and
I want to go back to the origins of
neuroscience he was born in 1852 did
most of his work in the late 1800s
continued to be productive afterwards
but his great discoveries were done in
the 1890s and he was a remark
guy he he wanted to be an artist his
father insisted he'd be pre-med they
fought over it but his father won and
then he ended up going to medical school
but decided that the thing he liked to
do most was draw so he became a
illustrator for pathologists and then
somebody showed him a Golgi stain I'll
explain what that is in a second which
is a stain of the brain and that just
changed his life course and all these
chemicals here and all these microscopes
were him modifying the Golgi stain in
order to see brain tissue so he's a
Spaniard and Golgi was an Italian
scientist Golgi is a very famous
histology you may have heard of the
Golgi tendon organ Golgi apparatus there
are a whole bunch of things inside
animals and humans that are named after
Golgi and one of the things he did
apparently in his kitchen was playing or
while he was playing around with
photographic emulsion materials he was
trying to see if he could get a stain
for tissue that took advantage of the
way silver stains worked in photography
and he mixed together two different
salts sodium nitrate and potassium
dichromate in just the right way that he
got a very very inefficient label of the
brain inefficient in the sense that the
vast majority of brain cells were not
labeled at all but any cell that had a
crystal of silver dichromate in it that
was an itis for crystallization and that
crystal would fill up the entire cell
but not cross the relatively hydrophobic
membranes so you could just get a whole
cell completely filled it was a very
unlikely event that this crystal would
form at all
so maybe 1 to 5 percent of the cells
would label and they would just label
randomly and everything else was
unlabeled and so for the first time it
was possible to see individual nerve
cells intact from beginning to end all
their processes and you may
nerve cells are very complicated they're
not just little cells they're cells but
they have all these wires sticking out
of them and Golgi generated this
remarkable tool that allowed you to see
these individual cells he was no match
though for cow who was a visual genius
and looked at this material and began to
infer things about the way the brain was
organized that Golgi himself were crazy
ideas and they shared the Nobel Prize
Golgi for the Golgi stain and cahal for
what he did with the Golgi stain and
it's kind of interesting to listen to or
read the Golgi Nobel lecture in 1906 I
think where he's standing next to kaha
and his whole lecture is basically
saying that qahal is an idiot
that he completely misunderstood the
Golgi stain and he turned out to be
largely incorrect about that so it was
unfortunate but kaha saw many wonderful
things he was a great neuroanatomist and
extraordinarily hard worker and I'll
show you the essence of what he found he
found that the nerve cells are not only
do they have these wires but the wires
can be divided into two types dendrites
that receive information and axons
that send information and that nerve
cells are connected together in a
directional network and here's the kind
of drawing he made so this is a drawing
it's not his most impressive drawing
there's actually an art exhibit of his
work traveling through the country right
now truly remarkable beautiful to see
his work this is a little piece of a
drawing he made of the cerebral cortex
of a cat and the paper has yellowed but
he didn't used whiteout to correct
little errors that no one else would
probably even have noticed but the
whiteout stood the test of time much
better than the paper so this has this
kind of look like snow on trees but
that's completely accidental but what
really is special about this picture
these are nerve cells this little thing
in the middle of each of them is a
nucleus
is these arrows so this is what cahal
said house big idea was that axons so
this is an axon of a nerve cell that
somewhere over here let's say and it
sends a branch an axonal branch that
terminates in a bunch of little branches
that overlap the shorter stubbier
branches of this neuron those branches
are dendrites and he claimed that at the
juxtaposition of axons and dendrites
some kind of information left the axon
jumped into the dendrites flowed into
the cell body of the cell and then was
sent out the axon of this cell see this
arrow here and that axon would overlap
the dendrites of another cell this is a
pyramidal cell in the cortex this
triangular shape this makes it called a
pyramidal cell and that information
would then flow down this apical
dendrite into the cell body and here's
another axon that's contacting the more
basal dendritic branches of the same
cell and together those inputs
collaborate in some way to generate a
signal that leaves this cell out its
axon notice the arrows this axon then
touches the apical dendrite of this
neuron that information flows to the
cell body and out that axon and this
axon does the same thing over here and
here in one fell swoop without ever
knowing what a synapse is this is before
synapses or how electrical currents flow
through nerve cells which was not yet
known just from dead material stained
with the Golgi stain he employee he
inferred a kind of directional network
which to this day is the standard
accepted notion of the way information
flows through nerve cells he didn't know
about things like inhibition which is a
very interesting fact that not every
axon is trying to make the cell send
information some axons
for example the axon going up in the
cortex like this is almost certainly an
inhibitory axon it's not trying to send
information that goes down it's crying
trying to shut down information of other
axons that might be contacting these
same dendrites he didn't know about that
so yeah one has to fault him that he
didn't know everything but how could he
possibly tell that from a Golgi stain
anyway but he was aware that there were
things he didn't understand here just a
remarkably insightful idea and to this
day most of us when we think about
neural circuits we draw them this kind
of way although this is based on a very
sparse labeling there's probably a
thousand cells in this area and hundreds
of thousands of axons coming in which
you don't see in this picture because
it's a Golgi stain but this is generally
the way we accept things to be and this
big idea had a big implication and the
big implication was the implication for
behavior which is that it actually is a
wiring diagram if you for example
activate the skin so here's an axon that
is making contact with the skin let's
say you stick a needle into the skin
that information would flow in to the
spinal cord and some of the branches of
that axon will touch the dendrites of a
cell maybe in the thalamus that cell
will send an axon up into the cerebral
cortex where it will touch the dendrites
of a pyramidal neuron that neuron will
then send that information back down to
the spinal cord where it will touch the
dendrites of a motor neuron in the
spinal cord a motor neuron makes
synapses on muscle fibers and so if you
get stuck with a pin or step on a pin
you're gonna lift your leg because of a
reflex like this similarly you could
imagine that if you're driving a car
you're driving along and suddenly a red
light appears you suddenly move your leg
muscles to push on the brake and if a
green light appears you move your leg
muscles to push on the gas this would be
again a wiring diagram basis for that
that there is sort of a connectional map
that that allows you to do these things
and of course you don't have a genetic
basis for stepping on the brake when
there's a red light this have to been
learned so this wiring diagram to do
something like stepping on the brake
when you see a red light or stepping on
the gas when you see a green light would
have to mean that this wiring
Graham was instantiated instantiated
based on experience so that's the big
idea but if one wants to actually see if
this theory has any legs you'd actually
have to be able to do this kind of
tracing and truth be told no one has
been able to do anything this big at all
not even close it's very difficult to do
this and one of the things that's
problematic about the Golgi stain is
that very very few cells label and
they're not the opportun cells it's just
random cells that label and we thought
maybe one way we could get the entire
network of what is going on is to label
all the cells
now if the Golgi stain labeled all the
cells that would be not very useful
because it'd just be a big brown mass
there just be label everywhere so what
you would want is some way of seeing
every single cell as an individual
without having the problem of ambiguity
of whether the process is coming from
one cell or another so how might we see
every individual cell is a single
cellular entity the way we thought about
this was color maybe we could make a
Technicolor Golgi where instead of just
having sparse labeling with this brown
label maybe every cell could be labeled
but each a different color that was the
idea and I will make a long story short
saying that we did something that I
think to people who are not expert in
the field may seem a little odd but is
now quite unremarkable which is we used
our brains to make a new kind of Mouse
this is not a mouse that evolved through
natural selection it's a mouse that
evolved through cognitive decisions of
human beings human beings have created
organisms that have special features and
in this case we took advantage of the
fact that there are proteins in
jellyfish and in corals that are
fluorescent and those proteins have
genes that make those fluorescent colors
and we could take those genes out of
jellyfish and out of corals and
transgenic ly engineer mice that now
Express
color inside the nervous system this
would never happen naturally there's no
way a jellyfish would have sex with a
mouse it would just never ever happen
but humans can do this quite easily and
then the way we got a lot of color is
that we had a red fluorescent protein a
green fluorescent protein and a blue
fluorescent protein and we only have
three photoreceptors red green and blue
preferring preferring photoreceptors
every color we see is basically a
mixture of how much red how much green
and how much blue comes back from a
particular place in the world so what we
did was we made transgenic Mouse with a
random amount of red green and blue in
each nerve cell and this is an example
of one of these Brainbow mice this is
the hippocampus and this is the cerebral
cortex all of these things here are
nerve cells and there's lots of color
here and we gave this this name brain
bow you know scientists are not that
funny so it's not that funny a name but
it always scientists at least laugh at
it I think that's clever it's not that
clever it's it but but that's what we
call the brain bow and I'll just zoom up
on this little part here if the lights
were down a little bit I think you'd get
a better impression but I think you can
see there's lots of color here and it's
really quite beautiful to look at brains
this way I'm going to show you one place
where we found we could use this to
great advantage which was by getting
these colors to be generated not in
every cell in the brain but specifically
in the cells in the spinal cord that go
to muscle fibers so the spinal cord sort
of is a butterfly shape and the cells at
the very bottom of this butterfly in the
anterior horn as it's called the ventral
horn of the spinal cord these are the
motor neurons who send axons out of the
brain and innervate contact those muscle
fibers that I showed you that diagram
from cahal of so if you take this animal
and trace out the peripheral branch
through the what's called the ventral
nerve root all the way out into a limb
you have these very long nerves where
all the axons are different colors and
when I saw this I was really
overwhelmingly happy I realized we had
built a remarkably powerful tool to
trace wires very long distances and I
was really patting myself on the back a
lot until an engineer friend of mine
reminded me that if you open up any
computer you will find that they figured
this out a long long time ago that if
you watch this a long way you
just color code them and so this is very
much like this and it is a form
interestingly of convergent evolution
where we're making animals now that have
the same property as the inside of trees
weird yeah weird anyway if you look at
this at higher power using a confocal
microscope you see the colors are
beautiful they really are great and then
if you trace these wires into muscle you
can then see which particular muscle
fiber is contacted by each of these
different axons which each come from a
different neuron because they're
different colors and this is an example
of looking in a muscle it'll take a
second for the memory to catch up here
and then it should play smoothly I hope
what you're seeing here are the ends of
those axons and they ended these things
that look like pretzels if you look
carefully these pretzels look like
they're clasping cylinders and the
reason they do is that there's muscle
fibers running this way and each muscle
fiber has a neuromuscular Junction a
place where an axon from a motor neuron
makes a connection with the muscle fiber
to make it contract and if you trace
along you'll have to trust me on this
you trace along a single muscle fiber
there's only one neuromuscular Junction
on a muscle fiber only one and not only
is there only once
right but there's only one axon at each
of these sites but the same axon can go
to different muscle fibers so for
example these two adjacent muscle fibers
happen to be contacted by the same
accent but this is a different neuron
that's a different neuron that's a
different neuron all these colors tell
you that there's a lot of neurons here
and this allowed us for the first time
to map out every single axon that goes
to a muscle and I'm going to show you
the result of this now I have to it has
to pause a second because this is very
large data here's one of these axons
that code to a muscle that pulls the ear
back in a mouse it's called the
inter-school tool Eris muscle and each
of these is one of those neuromuscular
junctions so here's an axon in an adult
mouse that's one axon and here's another
axon in the same muscle and here's
another one in the same muscle now you
notice I'm putting them in one at a time
this is because I have a contract with
julu who is the graduate student who did
this that whenever I show this I have to
show them one at a time because it took
so much work to trace all this that if I
just show it all at once it will demean
the amount of extraordinary effort it
took to get this done but I'm gonna put
them in one at a time and you may be
worried how long is this going to go on
there are only 15 axons altogether so
we're already more than halfway but I
have a contract with him I cannot I
cannot change this I have to go some of
them have a lot of branches and you see
now we're getting ones that are sparser
but they're distributed in some weird
weird way not in an obvious way and so
we'd not only did the left ear but we
did the right ear of the same mouse mice
are very symmetric and we did that in
six animals and it turned out that every
one of these branching patterns which we
call a connectome was unique every one
the wiring diagram was different from
every other one and this speaks to the
question about what are we going to
learn from wiring diagrams if every one
is
different from every other one something
that keeps me up at night
and there was something else about this
that was shocking to me there was a lot
of sub optimality useless loops
premature of branching I'll show you an
example so here's one of those
connectomes that julu did and all the
axons have been labeled blue here so
they don't confuse us and only one axon
is labeled red and this little box here
is blown up here all of the axons except
for to go this way one of them this blue
one that goes up here is a branch that
goes both directions and this red one is
the only axon in this particular animal
that just went this way now that that
who am I to judge it seems okay
perfectly fine except for the fact that
it makes a hairpin turn here and goes
all the way back down here and then goes
out again so that seems it I wouldn't
have done it that way I mean here for
example is a neuromuscular Junction
there's only one neuromuscular junction
of this axon down in this part of the
muscle there was an easy way to get
there like a little branch like this but
no it does this extraordinarily
circuitous route but that's not the
worst of it here's the bad one this
neuromuscular Junction is based on a
branch at right at this point so it's
fine you branch here and you should send
a branch there but that's not what
happens it branches here and both
branches go all the way up here and then
one branch peels off crosses over itself
to make that neuromuscular Junction so
we see lots of stuff like this it's not
perfect and when you look in insect
nervous systems and you look in worm
nervous systems you never see stuff like
this but in our Amalia nervous system
it's messy and it's not stereotyped so
what is that telling us where does all
this variability come from and the
answer is from development this is an
adult axon making a bunch of
neuromuscular junctions in a muscle this
is a different muscle not the
inter-school address but a little neck
muscle it
takes about 15 neuromuscular junctions
it's a two-week-old mouse we did the
same experiment of looking at a single
axon at birth and here's what this kind
of axon looks like at Birth a hell of a
lot more branches in fact every one of
these gray sites is a neuromuscular
Junction this one axon contacts 85% of
all the neuromuscular junctions here
whereas two weeks later it only contacts
5% so there's a massive massive amount
of branches here that disappear over age
and you know we did this with many
different samples and we could count the
number of muscle fibers in a motor unit
that's what this is called
and at birth it's about twelve times
bigger than the adult and its biggest at
birth and then as you can see when it
comes to the brains wiring at least of
muscle it's all downhill after birth you
start out complicated and you end up
simple that would be kind of the
backwards of what I would have thought I
guess I think that an adult is really
super smart and has all these ideas and
must have a very complicated wiring
diagram a baby can't even turn over and
it's just a blob of protoplasm it
shouldn't have anything and it's just
the opposite they baby's brain is or at
least the muscle is extremely
complicated at birth and simple later on
now this also infers something there's
another inference you could make here
because this is one axon in each case if
this one axon integrates 85 percent of
the muscle fibers then if every axon is
doing this there must be multiple axons
converging at each of these
neuromuscular junctions whereas there's
only one axon at each of these in the
adult there should be multiple ones here
and to see if that was true that would
be the expectation here we have to use a
technique that I'm going to speak a lot
about in a few minutes of serial
electron microscopy where we take image
after image of
neuromuscular Junction in this case and
stack them up align them there's the
muscle fiber striations and then see how
many axons are going to that one
neuromuscular Junction and it's amazing
there is not one axon there's not two
axons there's a whole bunch of axons
virtually every axon in the muscle is
going to that one muscle fiber so this
is one neuromuscular Junction and
there's one two three four five six
seven eight a very weak nine a weaker
ten and one that looks like it's already
on a way out eleven an extraordinary
amount of convergence and also each of
those axons had an extraordinary amount
of divergence at Birth now if you wait a
week at two weeks there's only one axon
left if you wait a week then most
neuromuscular junctions only have two
inputs and at that point we could
actually do time-lapse imaging so here
is a neuromuscular junction from a
postnatal day seven animal where one
axon has the left side of the synapse
and the other axon has the right sides
they kind of at some places they're sort
of squaring off and they're in
competition to see who will survive and
then we just followed this over time so
we would take a picture in this case at
postnatal day 11 the yellow axon looks
like it it's at a slight disadvantage
compared to the blue we took this
picture sewed up the wound came back
looked at the animal Riya nesset eyes
the baby mouse puppet post nailed a 12
and then you can see yellow has gained a
little and blue has lost a little did
the same thing at postnatal day 13
yellow has gained more blue has lost
more post no day 14 there's only yellow
their post no day 15 it kind of plumps
up so finally one axon becomes
victorious by invading the territory of
the competitor which is eliminated we
call this synapse elimination piece then
rains for most of the rest of the life
of the animal you can just come back
week after week and it's very boring
nothing
happens anymore and you have now a
monogamous relationship in muscle where
one axon and one target cell are coupled
and they remain coupled like that until
late and old age when one or the other
dies and then they have to find new new
mates but for most of the life they're
together so and you these this analogy
which sounds very sort of odd I think
you must remember that everything humans
do we do because our neurons are telling
us to do those things just like a
country behaves like the people in the
country to some degree I think humans
behave in some ways because this is
what's going on inside we have this
period in early life where we're trying
out lots of targets we're trying out
lots of ideas and then we eliminate a
lot and we end up being boring adults at
least that's what my children tell me
about me here so here is a summary of
this at birth you have this very
complicated all-to-all connectivity each
axon goes to many muscle fibers each
muscle fiber is contacted by many or
most of the axons and then you have this
remarkable amount of synapse elimination
and pruning where each axon ends up
being the sole proprietor of a series of
muscle fibers that are random relative
to another instantiation of this same
event so what could be going on during
this period that could be of value to
teach how it should wire up and I'm
going to show one more movie which is a
movie of what is happening to human kids
before they're walking and again they're
blobs of protoplasm but if you speed
them up and you watch what goes on you
see they're doing a lot of work that
seems almost insanely purposeful so
here's an example of a four hour time
lapse of a nine month old baby and I let
it speak for itself
[Music]
good
yeah
marriages are
in long catch you I'll never catch us go
sir get you out
Lee Marvin Luger for my Bella Nikki
[Music]
[Applause]
those are yes really what's going on I
think is we are making a lot of these
wires so the implications of the
profound of the profound rewiring theory
this is as close as I get to theory is
maybe mature circuits of nerve cells not
just muscle as the question emerge after
a period of pruning from a much more
interconnected nervous system of
juveniles pruning is mediated by neural
activity sensory experience and motor
practice that causes synapse elimination
we become what we become based on what
remains after pruning start out with the
potential to be many things but we end
up as a small subset I am a professor a
teacher and it has not it has crossed my
mind that education in this sense is
destructive destroying potential by
giving you the dogmatic line if I
impress any young people here today I
may be eliminating some alternative ways
of thinking about the world and that's I
don't know if that's good or bad that
that's what is what happens and
certainly you feel I'm sure when you
talk to your parents if you're young
that they seem a little more narrow
minded than you are and I know I'm not
narrow-minded but my children think I am
and I remember thinking that of my
parents so it's a real paradox I don't
quite get how this works so could it be
that the same thing is going on in mutt
that is going into muscles also
happening in the brain this is the big
question and I wish I could give you an
answer what we've been trying to figure
out is how to ask that question are we
instantiating memories by sculpting
neural circuits via the process of
synapse elimination it's a big idea I
have warned people in my lab if you have
an idea that makes sense to you almost
certainly it's wrong so I do understand
that but let me just tell you how we're
going about this we are trying to do the
equivalent of Brainbow but we can't use
optical light techniques because the
resolution limit of
the light microscope is too big we need
higher resolution and electron
microscopy does this so to people who
work with me Ken Hayworth and richard
schleck Richard is still in the lab ken
is now at janelia farm built a machine
that allows us to automatically generate
a filmstrip of brain tissue a filmstrip
and this is the film here and that is
the brain and I'll explain this is just
the elbow it looks like a movie
projector it's actually making a movie
it's making a film strip of sections and
let me just explain how that happens we
take a piece of brain and we slice it
against a diamond knife there's a water
boat here the sections float in the
water boat and then a conveyor belt
picks one up after another and here's a
little movie of that process going on
there so we're cutting a piece of brain
very thin 30 nanometers thick that's a
thousand to stick of the hair so they're
very thin they float into water and then
this conveyor boat you can see the
sections here are marching up on this
very thick carbon coated tap on Polly on
my Cape is getting a big cape and we can
get about 10,000 sections each 30 nano
meters six per day all automatic just
runs all day all night Christmas Eve
Sunday it doesn't matter it doesn't
the only thing every month my request is
oil which we're happy to give it and
then we take the tape we cut it into
strips and we put them on wafers and
then we image the wafers in an electron
microscope so here Bobby Kessler II who
developed the way of imaging it with
scanning electron microscopy is holding
his hand very still so we can see what
these sections look like and here is a
section of cerebral cortex and
hippocampus the place that I showed you
the brain bow from this is the same kind
of thing but now in the electron
microscope he's holding his breath now
going into the electron microscope those
are blood vessels these big white
objects are nerve cells these white
stripes are the apical dendrites of
neurons these black outlined objects are
myelinated axons these dark objects here
are mitochondria inside cells if we zoom
up and
finally you can see a cross-section of
an axon filled with these little
freckles these synaptic vesicles that
can chain newer transmitter up against a
dendritic spine so let me just label
this for you this is a dendrite from a
neuron and neuron dendrites have spines
a little thin necks spine apparatus and
a fat bulb at the end and that spine is
juxtaposed to an axon crop this is a
cross-section 30 nanometers thick and
the axon is releasing synaptic vesicle
contents right at a synaptic cleft so
this is the synapse so great we can see
all this really that's the good news the
bad news is here this is the image and
that is what I just showed you so this
is huge this is one by one millimeter so
it's not that big and in fact just to
get this whole thing at that resolution
requires us to take one two three four
five six 30 images and each of those
because the field of view of the
electron microscope is is only about
that big so you have to take 30 images
and this image itself took five hours to
take that image and we were doing five
million pixels per second so it's not
like we were going slow but still it
took a long time and what we're done
with those five hours we have now a
image at high resolution of something
that big and that's one square
millimeter let's say we want it to also
go a millimeter in depth to get a cubic
millimeter we would have to do that
33333 times and each of them took five
hours I did the math many many times I
did it over and over him trying to hope
that I had made a mistake but at that
imaging rate a cubic millimeter takes 17
years and you know I can't get any
graduate students to do this
postdocs are happy to do this because
they've got a job the Brethren students
don't want to take that long for their
PhD so we have to figure out a way to go
faster and I wouldn't be saying this if
there wasn't a way and so instead of 17
years we can now do this in six months
and this is the reason we partnered with
this company to build a machine that
would do this and that made me very
happy but not completely happy and for
two reasons one is I'm standing on a
chair then wheels this is it looks like
a refrigerator but it's a refrigerator
for Giants it's about ten feet tall it's
also called the multi Sam 505 that 505
gives you the impression that you know
they've been making these a long time
this is the multi 7.00 one this is the
very first one they made and that 505
was just there to make me feel better
and it took a while before it was
running but now it's running very nicely
it's a very strange machine it's very
fast as probably the fastest electron
microscope ever built
it generates 1112 terabytes a day
probably will be able to double that at
some point and it was designed for
connectomics it's an interesting machine
the reason it goes so fast is that
remember I have to take each of those
images one square after another to get
that hole all 30 squares taken
sequentially this machine has multiple
scanning beams in it if you take off the
cover that's what the underlying
engineering is a remarkable machine it
takes a electron source puts it through
a shower head and basically turns it
into 61 separate beams and each of those
beams scans a little box simultaneously
so you get 61 electron microscopes
working at the same time so this is one
machine that has a 61 fold speed build
up and and the 61 is because the one in
the middle is what makes the one and you
can if you have five million dollars you
can get a slightly more newer one that's
91 beam
where there's still one in the know so
this is what the images look like this
sort of hexagonal images so each of
these boxes get made at the same time
and then to generate a cubic millimeter
because this is only 100 microns you
tile these and this is done
automatically
you just have a stage that moves
automatically to tile let's say a square
millimeter I've sped this up a little
bit what used to take five hours now can
be done in five minutes so that's a big
speed-up and then you get images that
look like this it's sort of weird and
then you have to align them this turns
out to be a big issue because these
images are extraordinarily large and
although this doesn't look aligned
because they're jumping around actually
the nerve cells you see aren't moving at
all
so we use multi-core clusters to do this
very sophisticated very heavy
computational challenges to do alignment
and then if you just look at a little
region like this this is what the data
looks like so now we're going to play
it's not a it's a space lapse we're
playing through the e/m data of the
aligned data these are nerve cells and
then all these little things here this
is another nerve cell with its nucleus
coming in all this stuff moving around
is just moving in space objects that are
moving at some Direction relative to the
cut of these images it's fascinating to
look at and you can already imagine that
there may be a way you could just trace
out all these wires because you have
enough resolution here to see everything
that's the nucleolus of a neuron that's
a blood vessel up there we zoom up a
little higher magnification now you'll
see every single synapse you can follow
these objects easily enough and every
once a while you'll see something filled
with freckles those are the synaptic
terminals that are filled with stuff
like that and then you can just build a
volume here's a nuclear membrane with
pores nucleolus that's coming into field
of view it'll go out and then other
parts will come back in
so this is very high-resolution just a
small part of the volumes like this so
you end up with a box of brain basically
a you could have a cube like this where
everything is rendered at four by four
nanometers and you're cutting at 30
nanometers and this is a very small data
set just two terabytes but this is a
kind of data set that we started with so
when you have a data set like that then
you have to turn it into a wiring
diagram and one way to do this is just
have a human being do it and any child
can do this and now it turns out
computers can as well so you you color
in an object like a dendrite in section
after section if you keep doing that you
can generate the three-dimensional
version of that object going through the
data so this is a dendrite with a bunch
of spines and there's an axon making
synapses on two of those spines so it
works and that's good training data for
convolutional neural nets by the way to
get them to learn how to do this as well
so here is the vesicles and the axon
making a synapse on a dendritic spine of
course you don't just want to do two
things you want to do everything so here
is a data set where this tool that
Daniel Berger wrote vast which is just
sort of digital coloring book allows
people to color in so anyone who wants
to do this we have an infinite amount of
data that needs to be colored in so if
you like coloring and you want to do
that for a living I can pay you minimum
wage to color for as much as you want so
this is a a red dendrite a big apical
dendrite of a pyramidal cell running
right through the middle here it'll come
back that has spines coming off of it
and this was part of a paper where the
purpose of the paper was just to ask
what is within a spine distance of a
neuron since it has all these spines
what is there what is in the brain
within that distance how many objects
are there we didn't really know
but after we did this we didn't know and
it wasn't a pretty sight so here are the
two dendrites we reconstructed with
their spines and these were not the only
dendrites that were in the volume of
course there's lots of other stuff
pushed in there here and that's the
dendritic spine that sticks out the
furthest I'll come back to that in a
second here are all the other dendrites
of other nerve cells that are pushed in
surrounding these two dendrites so their
spines now our heart are just barely
visible the dendrites of course are only
part of the nervous system there have to
be axons as well turns out we found
about eight times more axons in this
volume than dendrites here are all the
axons now I know this looks impossible
how can that and that be the same place
don't they bump into each other but
wherever you see a dendrite there's no
accident so everywhere there isn't axons
at dendrites there's axons and there's
more axons and dendrites interestingly
and there's also supporting cells called
glia and there's all the glia that's in
there too so that's everything in there
peeking out is that little green
dendrite and then this an exploded view
just gives you a sense of what's in
there and I like to say this is either
depressing or very depressing I I don't
know what else to say about this the
insane number of things squeezed in to
this very very small area which is a
trivially small part of the brain this
is about one trillionth of a mouse brain
this also took us five years to
reconstruct so I don't I'm not going to
do the math about that but in there were
an extraordinary number of objects and
we could classify them there were many
types of axons there were some that were
myelinated some that were inhibitory
some that were excitatory they were
oligodendrocyte s' spiny dendrites
smooth dendrites different type of type
of neuron and embarrassingly a bunch of
things that didn't look like anything
we'd ever seen before and some of these
are still on where unclear what they are
even though we could trace them very
long distances they never really declare
themselves as something that we've seen
in the textbooks so there are some you
know deep mystery
there but from this we learned a number
of things I'm not going to go through
the details except to say that we now
have a tool that allows us to see
everything every synaptic vesical these
little white dots are the synaptic
vesicles in every axons synapse on every
dendritic spine is visible and so this
is good news and I'm just going to end
by saying where we're taking this now
that we can do this we should do
cortical circuits and we have decided to
do cortical circuits of human brain of
human tissue that is taken from living
humans who for one reason or another
have to give up a little brain to have a
medical procedure so it's extremely well
preserved tissue but it's from people
who are walking around and it allows us
to get cortical of humans the cortex of
humans the neurosurgeons say we're going
to give you just a little piece I said
of course you can I don't want give me a
lot
they give us pieces that are the size of
a mouse brain this is really disturbing
we can give up a mouse brain worth of
brain and still be okay
but apparently there's large parts of
the brain where neurosurgeons say yeah
they can do what they want it doesn't
really change so the data set that we're
working on right now is so big that we
fortuitously I got a call from a Varenne
Jain at Google and he said you have a
big project I said do I have a big
project and so we have a piece of human
cerebral cortex that's very big this is
three millimeters by two millimeters I
know for you that doesn't seem so big
but for us that's big this is 750 1000
pixels by 500,000 pixels so this image
this one image these are nerve cells
here is 375 gigabytes that means three
of these images is a terabyte and we
have 5000 of them so it's one point
eight five petabytes that's 1,850
terabytes or
1.8 billion megabytes so it is a lot of
data it all has to be aligned and then
it all has to be segmented and of
arraign and his colleagues have taken
this very seriously and just yesterday
they sent me the first segmentation done
entirely by artificial neural networks
and it's a little piece of this but they
are going to do the entire cortex all
the way through all the layers and I
just couldn't help myself since they had
already done few hundred sections to
reconstruct some of it this all just
came right out of their stuff without
just some training from us and in there
were beautiful axons making synapses on
spines where no human being did this
this was done entirely by computational
tools so this is fully automated
rendering of human cortical circuits via
artificial neural networks and they'll
wrap your head around that a little bit
what does that mean what is where are we
going this is very disturbing and I
think I just want to end with what has
transformed in my lifetime so
information and understanding I think
have always been tied together
scientists always say I am doing these
experiments to understand something and
the great complexity problem coming at
us is that when I was young we had lots
of really great ideas big ideas and
nothing got in the way we had a lot of
pseudo understanding but there was
nothing over here to tell us whether we
were right or wrong that was the way it
was and this is the way it is now we we
are now generating extraordinary amounts
of information and it seems to me that
the biggest casualty of all this big
data may be Big Ideas and we're gonna
have to come up with another way to deal
with this extraordinary explosion of
information and that it may not boil
down to an idea as simple as synapse
elimination maybe it will in my mind it
seems reasonable but as I said if it
seems reasonable
almost
it's not the right answer what is the
right answer I don't know but this is
the philosophical problem of our time
which is sort of how to leverage
information without trying to turn it
into linguistic words are there models
that we can use that we may never
understand in the linguistic sense of
being able to explain it but they work
so I'm going to end with that and just
remind you I did very little of this I
have many many colleagues who have
worked with many collaborators and
support from many sources because this
is very expensive work and I'm happy to
take questions not to make it even more
difficult but have you looked in thread
at intrauterine mice brains to actually
see how the brain developed from you
know very limited connections to the
high density of connections at birth and
then obviously the pruning afterwards we
looked in muscle at earlier stages than
birth and you may remember that Pete it
peaked at birth in fact things are
simpler before birth and then they get a
peak at birth but before birth you're
still making synapses you're just sort
of building the nervous system so it's
simple not so much because there isn't
fan-in and fan-out there just not not a
lot of cellular elements yet the cortex
is a very complicated tissue in that
there are waves of development for
different parts of the brain different
layers of the brain mature at different
times so at some point of course I mean
going back to babies I I'd like to do
human babies it's hard enough to get
adult tissue it's very hard to imagine
getting good quality human baby tissue
so I'm not sure how we're gonna do that
but we are definitely for me I have to
do the adult first to know if a baby's
different if I said if I do a baby
without knowing what the adult looks
like I won't be able to be very informed
so we have to start with the adult but I
agree with you we have to go back to
birth and then perhaps even before birth
I'm assuming if these are things related
to experience
then it really gets going after birth
that those first nine months there's
some kicking in the womb for humans and
other animals they do some motor
development before birth but I have a
feeling for mammals especially in humans
it's what happens after the birth that
really matters so you would say that
birth means that when the organism gets
exposed to outside stimulus besides the
womb and the mother and that yeah that's
what I would say is that little line
comes in with your dumb your chart or
your diagram that is where that peak was
was the day of birth it was amazing the
day of birth was the most complicated
the muscle system is
so you talked about the artificial
neural networks a little bit and so I'm
curious from your point of view because
I have a computer science background
what are the main similarities between
the artificial networks that we use
nowadays in machine learning and another
question may be related say we are able
to overcome all the computational
difficulties and we can map the whole
brain would this be useful in any way to
simulate a human being and is that in
your opinion possible in the future I
mean the technical question about how
artificial neural networks are different
from natural neural networks when we
prune to zero that connection is gone
and can't come back in most networks
there's an architecture that allows the
weight to be anywhere from zero to one
but there's nothing zero is not a
one-way street that is it's just one of
the states in in humans and in other
animals the zeros actually simplify the
network tremendously so that at the end
there's not as many competing voices
deciding what to do and that's why you
know you may not trust a baby two years
of age alone in a house because they're
gonna maybe try to stick a fork in the
plug because that's interesting there's
a hole and I've got something with
sparkles in it whereas you'll trust the
two-year-old dog because they're not
that curious anymore by two maybe a two
month old dog you wouldn't trust alone
but a two-year-old dog you would so I
don't know you know at what point
artificial networks will start to try to
think about this maybe the people are
already doing this to simplify the
network by culling out of the network
the the layered network things that
aren't working so that there's no wasted
time going through the zeros anymore
that would be like pruning the other
thing is that in actual neural networks
there's a huge amount of recurrent
connectivity so for example the retina
goes to the thalamus and the thalamus
goes to the visual cortex that's the way
information flows in but the number of
axons going from visual cortex to
thalamus is ten times greater than the
number of axons going from retina mm as'
so the back propagation direction is is
bigger than the forward one and I'm not
sure in neural networks that there is
anything like that yet and then what
could we make a human being in silico is
that what you're saying many people
think so
ken Hayworth who helped make the Adam
device who's at janelia farm
I think believed that the only way
humans will ever communicate with people
or sentient beings on other places is by
sending the wiring diagram at the speed
of light broadcasting it into space and
having the person recreated at the other
at least their brain recreated now that
sounds very fanciful but maybe I don't
know
so most Bruins are very complicated
many animals but I remember 50 years ago
Sydney Brandner studied began study C
elegans symbol forums and it has just
few hundred cells I think he started to
understand neural system of this world
and I think it's failed no just
wondering how understanding all the
simple animals like forums versus all I
would never call a worm a simple animal
I would put a hyper evolved animal that
has managed to get all of its behaviors
with only 300 nerve cells that's not
easy
that requires maybe a billion years of
evolution so it's an extremely
complicated nervous system because every
nerve cell has extraordinary tricks that
are different from every other nerve
cell it's one of the hardest nerve cell
animals to figure out and I know because
with era V Samuel we are doing every
developmental stage of C elegans and be
publishing a paper in a few months on
that work and it's interesting but it is
not simple and and every time people
talk about C elegans as a simple
organism I say you want to see simple
look at the brain of a human being where
you have the same nerve cell over and
over and over again you just have little
variations in the wiring but it's just a
very redundant nervous system it's like
the difference between a Nintendo chip
you know that's been made for one very
specific purpose and a generic computer
that can learn anything this is a simple
brain if we come into the world much
less fipt than a worm a worm doesn't
have to learn anything it's all built in
that's a lot harder
we just have one algorithm a learning
algorithm nobody understands it but
that's that's it whether it comes in
through your eyes or your ears it wires
you up that's simple
in my mind so I and when people say to
me why are you working on a hard animal
as well
simple animal I say I'm working on a big
animal with a lot of redundancy as
opposed to a little animal where every
single thing is an exception based on
evolution so but no one would say it
failed who really works in that area
they use that connectome a lot it's just
there have been some naysayers who just
don't like the notion that we should
actually describe wiring diagrams they
say it's worthless you know it's like
saying there's no point in using the
Hubble telescope because it's worthless
there's just so much stuff out there
you'll never make sense of it no one
would say that about astronomy or people
who do archeology and find new dinosaurs
it's worthless because there's so many
different kinds of dinosaurs but when it
comes to brains it's worthless we don't
want to look I just I'm sorry you see
I'm I have fought this fight so many
times
I wonder what your thoughts are on that
going from the static image to sort of
modeling dynamics kind of flowing
information flowing through the system
so there are two kinds of dynamics you
know there's the dynamics of the actual
flow of information through these wiring
diagrams which you don't get from these
static images in fact most of that stuff
is initiated based on information coming
from the sensory world which is not in
the nervous system but it's in the world
that is driving it the ideas you have
based on what you just heard or saw
that's invisible and that's a profound
problem but anything you've memorized
anything you know must somehow be
instantiated in those wires how nobody
knows but there is a trace an Engram of
the activity patterns the experiences
you've had that is somehow embedded in
those wiring diagrams in mammals I
believe the other kind of dynamics that
a lot of people say as well the nervous
system is constantly changing you're
learning new things and I say well
that's a baby but as an adult and my
colleague said well I learn all the time
I you know when I thought of my parents
they didn't learn that much I would tell
them things that were really interesting
so that's really interesting
next time I'd see them I'd have to tell
him again and it wasn't that they had
Alzheimer's it just went in one ear and
out the other didn't care and I think so
I don't think there's that much
plasticity and this is a very you know
extreme view that plasticity and adults
is hard that guy spent eight months
learning to ride a bicycle you know if
it was that hard as a child no one would
learn to ride a bicycle for adults to
learn a new language to learn to ride a
bicycle to do for me to learn Twitter at
this point it's hopeless
do it
it's really profound a lecture I was
thinking about that which you started
out talking about comparing casual
Ramone casual and Golgi and you know I
think in more contemporary ways that
goals would create a second technology
ability to see the anatomy and but but
you know Ramon the casual came up with
this crazy idea showing directionality
in a way would you say that we are
showing now is more analogous to Golgi
and if so what where do you think the
possible entry points are for creative
work on this so-called genius was to
come up with an idea that was simple
enough that everyone could understand
and those ideas have real power in the
fact that we're now 140 years later if
you ask me to draw a neural circuit for
you I'll draw it in a Coleen way with
these arrows
it is very profoundly easy to think
about it that way I think the truth of
the matter is that it is much more
complicated than that simple-minded idea
there is a lot more for example local
interactions I didn't actually show much
neurobiology data but we have just
finished reconstructing a nerve cell in
the thalamus it's it called a local
inter neuron and it's inhibitory and
every single process is both an axon and
a dendrite every process both sends
information and receives information and
works locally it's not collecting
information and sending it out the axon
it's doing local circuit motifs
everywhere along its branches and it has
thousands of synapses that's that
doesn't fit the Kahala worldview but
it's definitely in the nervous system so
yeah I think you know Golgi I think got
a bad rap because it turned out there is
a kind of synapse called electrical
synapses where cells are just connected
to each other in a syncytium that's what
he's
it was just a diffuse neural network
there's no directionality information
can flow both ways there are synapses
like that he would he was not you know
he was clearly a great scientist he got
a Nobel Prize I mean he just wasted his
Nobel lecture I would say that's the
only thing he did wrong he should have
bragged about what he did rather than
argue the other way all right I might
cut the discussion short
okay points oh thank you all for coming
and I hope to see you next time and
please join me in thanking Jeff once
again